nouvelle calédonie accord sur l'avenir
du territoire le fln ks c'est le rpr le
qualifie même de termes de victoires
victoire des bonnes volontés sur les
égoïsmes partisans tout est prêt pour un
référendum en irlande du nord les
terroristes de l'ira redouble de
violence ils font exploser un autre bus
de l'armée britannique
sept morts et 29 blessés une femme et
cinq coups francs après neuf ans de
traitement contre la stérilité une jeune
lyonnaise met au monde des quintuplés
ils vont bien la maman aussi le pape a
également madame monsieur bonsoir c'est
déjà de l'histoire il y a vingt ans dans
la nuit du 20 au 21 août
le printemps de prague s'achevait au
beau milieu de l'été souvenirs en forme
d'inventaire pêle-mêle double check
svoboda socialisme à visage humain des
noms des termes oublier remplacé depuis
par un seul mot insignifiant est
terrible à la fois normalisation les
films de laser prague depuis vingt ans
des bouquets anonyme fleuriste un coin
de trottoir à 4 pas de la statue
équestre du roi venceslas c'est là qu'un
garçon de 18 ans s'est immolé par le feu
pour protester contre l'invasion de son
pays
il s'appelait jan palach ultime symbole
de l'anéantissement du printemps de
prague par les chars des pays frères du
pacte de varsovie
il était un peu plus de deux heures au
matin du 21 août 68 quand les chenilles
d'été 64 ont réveillé les habitants de
prague
quelques heures plus tard ils étaient
des milliers dans la rue à hurler leur
stupeur et leur chagrin à ces soldats
qui ne semblait pas savoir ce qu'ils
étaient venus faire eux mêmes dans ce
pays
alexandre du tchèque celui par qui
l'espoir était arrivé sept mois plus tôt
en remplaçant le 5 janvier 68 à la tête
du parti communiste tchèque
l'ultra-conservateur antonine de botnie
du tchèque marqué la fin d'une période
de répression et le début du printemps
lors du printemps de prague douchez que
un président et aux réformes
essentielles qui ont été des réformes
très importantes de la vie politique
tchécoslovaque
d'une part la démocratie plus grande un
terreau de la société la prise de parole
et plupart des tchèques quoi en contre à
prague vous parle de cette libération de
la parole ensuite le retour sur le passé
la possibilité de dire la vérité sur le
passé stalinien sur les procès des
années 50
procès d'arthur long dont notamment et
puis enfin je dirais la possibilité
l'ouverture d'une discussion interne des
entreprises
une discussion libre sur l'ensemble de
la vie économique et sociale
douch est il a présidé à tous à la voix
tchécoslovaque vers le socialisme défini
par duch ex et vnnic et ôta sic inquiète
de plus en plus moscou et les durs du
camp socialiste mis en garde
avertissements menace rien ne peut
arrêter l'enthousiasmé populaire
le petit homme de prague ne pourra
empêcher ce qu'on appelle la
normalisation au matin du 21 août 1968
5000 chars et six cent mille soldats
envahissent son pays
un an plus tard nous tchèque doit céder
sa place politiquement et humainement
brisé c'est la fin de la résistance la
fin officielle du printemps de prague
devenu jardinier
aujourd'hui retraité dans sa maison de
bratislava alexandre double check sur
200 passé reconnaît ses idées dans les
initiatives récentes de moscou duch
éclatant gorbatchev
il y avait encore pas de chef parce que
pour lui et c'est l'homme de la presse
troïka l'homme de la glace nost et pour
lui car historique avec la sono
s'inspire des idées du printemps de
prague
contrairement à ce qu'il se passe
actuellement en urss ni les
tchécoslovaques ni les polonais ni les
hongrois ne sont autorisés à critiquer
le passé et l'attitude du grand frère
soviétique
une lacune dans la politique d'ouverture
prônée par mikhaïl gorbatchev
après l'histoire il ya l'actualité
la nouvelle calédonie aujourd'hui
l'accord signé ce matin à l'aube à paris
parachève le premier texte ratifié au
mois de juin à l'hôtel matignon entre
indépendantistes et anti
indépendantistes et il servira de base
certainement au référendum qui doit être
organisée à l'automne sur l'avenir du
territoire et qui concernera l'ensemble
des français pour le fln caresse comme
pour le rpcr c'est une victoire et
laissant volontairement de côté des
arrière pensées des deux camps il faut y
voir une défaite des égoïsmes et une
réelle volonté d'assurer la paix civile
en nouvelle calédonie rachid arhab jean
françois beck deux jours et trois nuits
de discussion des semaines de
négociation des mois d'incertitude des
années de crise la poignée de main
tjibaou luc et ouais à presque toutes
effacées en quelques secondes
tout pourtant opposé les frères ennemis
de nouvelle calédonie aujourd'hui ils
parlent presque la même langue
tous ensemble
elles donnent fière de toutes origines
sont près aussi aujourd'hui à participer
et à faire en sorte que notre pays notre
territoire puisse être l'image de marque
de la france dans cette région du monde
mais aussi d'un pays heureux et libres
d'espérer est une science en nous
huit ans pour personne
c'est sûr qu'on a avec ce soir certes
les problèmes de fond ne sont pas tous
réglés par la corde ce matin mais la
signature du texte par les deux
délégations oblige le rpcr et le fln
caisse a continué le dialogue sur place
aujourd'hui n'est pas une arrivée
c'est une étape il faudra beaucoup
d'efforts de courage et de confiance
tout au long de ces dix années
mais les délégations qui se sont réunis
ont démontré qu'il n'y avait aucune
fatalité de l'échec et de la violence
le rapprochement des deux camps et
surtout l'oeuvre de michel rocard
le premier ministre qui dès sa
nomination avait pris le dossier en main
menant lui même les accords de matignon
du 26 juin dernier le premier ministre
qui réussit là une excellente opération
de politique intérieure en effet tout le
monde attendait michel rocard au
tournant caledonia ayant prouvé que sa
méthode de travail a été efficace le
premier ministre peut espérer que
l'opinion du accordera sa confiance pour
le règlement d'autres dossiers
politiques
la rentrée sociale le budget ou encore
les élections cantonales et municipales
bref ayant engrangé un capital de bons
points
michel rocard peut espérer puiser dans
ce capital au mieux préparer sa rentrée
politique
oui pour parvenir à l'accord les deux
parties vous en doutez ont fait un
certain nombre de concessions sur
l'ampleur de la nuit ch'ti notamment la
répartition des pouvoirs régionaux avec
l'assurance d'obtenir des moyens
financiers permettant à un développement
économique du territoire
pendant cette période transitoire de dix
ans avant l'autodétermination bruno
roger-petit 120 articles dans ce projet
120 articles d'où émergent quatre grands
points 4 points vitaux de l'accord
d'abord le découpage du territoire
le projet prévoit la création de trois
provinces gérer chacune par une
assemblée et un président la réunion des
trois assemblées formeraient le congrès
congrès administrant le territoire avec
le haut commissaire du gouvernement
deuxième point l'économie et le social
aux 300 millions de francs débloqués par
le gouvernement s'ajoute d'autres moyens
notamment des contrats et à province le
projet indique même que le premier
bénéficiaire devrait en être la
communauté mélanésienne troisième point
le corps électoral en 98 seul voteront
les électeurs participant au référendum
de l'automne prochain et leurs
descendants
en outre le projet prévoit 3 révision
exceptionnelle des listes électorales
d'ici à dix ans enfin l'amnestie pour le
moment serait amnistier les infractions
commises sur le territoire en relation
avec la détermination du statut
une formulation suffisamment large pour
laisser libre cours à toutes les
éventualités
oui ce soir monsieur diva ou envisagent
même que les militants incarcérés pour
crimes de sang soient libérés dans un
délai assez rapide avant noël tout le
monde aura retrouvé sa famille vient il
de déclarer à nos confrères de fr3 les
réactions politiques à cet accord sont
favorables du côté du parti socialiste
bien entendu on se félicite ce groupe és
de l'exploit du gouvernement de michel
rocard
dans l'opposition le rpr est également
satisfait de notes discordantes à nouméa
le front national qui voit dans
l'adoption de ce texte la trahison des
anti-indépendantistes par le rpcr le rpr
locales et dans l'autre camp le fut
l'une des composantes minoritaire il
faut le dire du fln k s qui refusent de
s'associer à l'accord signé ce matin car
celui ci aurait dû être selon cette
organisation discuté par le mouvement
avant d'être acceptée à l'étranger
l'information du jour c'est le cessez le
feu entre l'iran et l'irak cessez-le-feu
effectif depuis ce matin 5 heures huit
années de guerre et déjà une journée de
paix et de manière de célébrer
l'événement liesse à bagdad en irak
kamaté rang et déjà également un premier
test pour les deux ennemis d'hier
les irakiens ont décidé de reprendre la
navigation dans le golfe
claude crespo un des premiers tests pour
vérifier l'application du cessez le feu
le golfe arabo persique dès ce matin un
pétrolier irakien a fendu saison cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis huit ans un
second doit incessamment le suivre
décision de l'iran sa marine effectuera
des missions d'inspection les navires
dans le coin un contrôle rejeté sans
ambages par les irakiens
officiellement la paix des armes entre
l'iran et l'irak
à peine 20 heures d'âge les trois cent
cinquante officiers de l'onu se sont
maintenant déployé tout au long des 12
200 kilomètres des frontières et selon
qu'il était à bagdad ou à téhéran ils
ont pu observer des réactions totalement
différente
la liesse en irak
sans un coup de canon tirés dans toutes
les villes du pays la fête dans les rues
la joie sur les visages mais à téhéran
le calme est aussi le soulagement de
vivre la fin d'un conflit qui aura fait
un million et demi de victimes des deux
côtés ce climat d'expectative me méfiant
semi soulagement va durer jusqu'à jeudi
prochain à genève sous la houlette de
xavier perret de décollage les
négociations directes commenceront le
secrétaire général de l'onu sait déjà
que la partie sera difficile la
constitution de la commission chargée
d'établir la responsabilité de cette
guerre sera un test décisif
la parole est donc désormais aux
diplomates dans ce conflit des
négociations directes on viens de vous
le dire doivent s'engager la semaine
prochaine entre l'iran et l'irak à
genève des deux côtés pour l'instant le
mot d'ordre est à la prudence prudence
pour tenter de faire tenir cette paix
fragile comme en témoigne cette double
interview des ambassadeurs de téhéran et
de bagdad à paris ils s'en tiennent à la
résolution 598 des nations unies qui
prévoit dans un premier temps un cessez
le feu et la mort ce d'une négociation
font remarquer l'oms seul fo est entrée
en vigueur
nous le resterons bien sûr nous espérons
que ce sera le premier pas essentiel que
la révolution 598 soient bien appliquées
et nous espérons au seul faux sociale fo
sera continué jusqu'au bout on arrive à
une paix durable réjouissent dans nos
régions à votre avis dans ces
négociations entre iraniens et irakiens
qu'elle est l'obstacle majeur en
principe jo wood ses obsèques major
source ce sujet mais si je me base sur
l'attitude précédent du régime d'irak
j'espère qu'ils ne créent pas des
optiques nous irakiens prions seniors
avec l'espoir pour que le cessez le feu
d'aujourd'hui conduisent un règlement
pacifique définitif pour l'irak comme
pour
entre avis quel sera le plus gros
obstacle dans les négociations de genève
oui il n'ya pas pour nous des obstacles
spécifiques car la résolution des
nations-unies et fait de clauses dont
chacune est lié à l'autre
s'il ya une bonne volonté de part et
d'autre comme c'est le cas du côté de
l'irak
nous sommes convaincus que tous les
problèmes peuvent trouver une solution
voilà et pour en terminer avec ce
dossier souvenez vous au mois de juin
dernier
l'événement le dernier événement
tragique de cette guerre aura été la
destruction par un missile de la flotte
américaine d'un airbus iranien et à ce
propos le pentagone le ministère de
défense américain a rendu public
aujourd'hui les conclusions sont donc
bien le commandant et l'équipage du
croiseur vincennes qui avait tiré sont
blanchis aucune accusation grave n'est
portée contre eux tout juste quelques
erreurs d'appréciation delphine de l'
erreur humaine sans aucun doute le
capitaine du vincennes et ses hommes ont
mal interprété les données des plus
performants radar de la flotte
américaine
c'était le 3 juillet dernier tension
maximum dans le golfe le croiseur
américain vient de repousser une attaque
de vedettes iraniennes
peu après sur les écrans radar du
vincennes un avion étranger non
identifiables semble s'approcher les
officiers sont sur le qui-vive et sept
minutes plus tard
l'ordre est donné d'abattre l'avion
identifié cette fois comme un chasseur
iranien c'était un airbus civil
il y aura 2 190 morts après un mois et
demi dans quête le rapport sur cette
tragédie tête apparaître les erreurs
suivante de la part de l'équipage
le code radars de l'airbus iranien a été
mal interprétés la trajectoire de
l'avion n'était pas menaçante
elle correspondait au couloir aérien
civil le pentagone a rendu son verdict
le commandant du vincennes will rogers a
fait son devoir
le secrétaire d'état à la défense frank
carlucci a précisé qu'il ne dresserait
aucune lettre de censure aux officiers
coupable d'erreurs
le président ronald reagan a approuvé sa
décision
les terroristes irlandais de l'ira
n'auront attendu que quelques heures
avant de revendiquer l'attentât commis
la nuit dernière en y
land du nord contre un autocar
transportant des soldats britanniques
le véhicule a été littéralement soufflé
par l'explosion
bilan 7 morts 29 blessés jean-marc il
aux sept morts et 28 blessés un bilan
encore provisoire de cette embuscade à
l'explosif tendu la nuit dernière en
rase campagne à l'autobus qui ramenait
de belfast 30 saint père missionnaire
des forces britanniques en irlande du
nord
un cratère de deux mètres de profondeur
le but c'est littéralement pulvérisé
sous l'effet de 90 kilos d'explosifs de
type centex précisions fournies dans un
communiqué par les auteurs eux mêmes de
cet attentat signé hier à du nom de
l'armée clandestine les nationalistes
irlandais en guerre ouverte avec ce
qu'ils appellent le gouvernement
colonial britannique à londres le
premier ministre margaret thatcher
adversaire acharné je cite des
terroristes de l'ira a abrégé
immédiatement ses vacances c'est
l'attentât le plus sanglant commis
depuis neuf ans contre l'armée
britannique en irlande du nord depuis
dix mille soldats britanniques sont
cantonnés en irlande du nord
officiellement pour appuyer la police et
empêché de sanglants affrontements entre
deux communautés et leurs extrémistes
respectifs
l'une minoritaires catholique et
nationaliste favorable à une irlande
réunifiée l'autre majoritaire
protestante et loyalistes attachés à la
couronne et qui veut rester britannique
au même titre que l'ecosse ou le pays de
galles en 20 ans ce conflit a fait 2600
morts dont 400 soldats britanniques
tombés dans des attentats en irlande du
nord et plus récemment en europe même
jean-marc il use vous rentrez d'irlande
du nord vous nous présenter
prochainement au cours des journaux
télévisés une série de reportages sur la
situation là bas mais tout de même une
question ce soir pourquoi cette
recrudescence du terrorisme et des
actions de plus en plus violentes de
l'ira contre l'armée britannique est
bien le premier objectif de l'ira c'est
de frapper l'opinion britannique les
sondages le disent 50 % d'entre eux sont
hostiles à ce conflit sanglant et
coûteux or pour le gouvernement de
londres
il n'est pas question de tourner les
talons laisser le champ libre aux
extrémistes c'est basculer dans une
nouvelle guerre civile
deuxième objectif de cette campagne
d'attentats barrer la route à tout
compromis
les extrémistes nationalistes comme leur
triste homologue loyalistes sont prêts à
tout pour saboter la timide de
tentatives de rapprochement que tente
depuis trois ans par dessus leur tête
les gouvernements de londres et de
dublin la capitale de la république
d'irlande une terrible politique de
surenchère parce qu'on est presque à la
veille du 20e anniversaire de l'arrivée
des troupes britanniques
une politique qui risque bien de ranimer
les vieux réflexes de peur et de haine
entre communautés non plus seulement
nationaliste contre loyalistes mais
hélas entre catholiques et protestants
en pologne on est au bord de l'épreuve
de force entre les ouvriers des asiri
des mines des chantiers navals et le
gouvernement du général jaruszalski qui
refuse catégoriquement de légaliser à
nouveau solidarité de syndicat créé par
les cheval est ça qui avait été reconnue
officiellement en 1981 est dissous après
le coup d'état du général jaruzelski à
noter aujourd'hui que les syndicats
officiels conteste également la
politique économique et sociale
actuellement suivi par le gouvernement
polonais et puis cette dépêche qui est
tombé quelques minutes après 20 heures
et qui laisse mal augurer de l'avenir en
ce moment même à varsovie de la
direction suprême des forces armées
polonaises est réuni sous la présidence
du chef de l'état du chef du parti le
général jacques osele ce qui pour
prendre des décisions appropriées
suite aux dangers qui menacent depuis
quelques jours la pologne voici le texte
de la dépêche
alors ces menaces entre guillemets bien
entendu sont en rapport
avec la situation économique et sociale
que je viens de vous décrire une
information à prendre très au sérieux
avec peut-être de développement dans la
soirée le pakistan a enterré aujourd'hui
le général zia le chef de l'état décédé
jeudi dans un accident d'avion une thèse
de plus en plus controversé d'ailleurs
l'accident pourrait être en fait un
attentat un engin explosif télécommandé
ayant été placé à bord de l'appareil
aujourd'hui à islamabad plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes
assistaient aux obsèques du général zia
françois joly ils ont grimpé jusqu'à 30
mètres du sol sur le toit de la mosquée
feisal d'islamabad
parce qu'ils étaient cinq cent mille
pakistanais devant ce bâtiment venus
rendre un dernier hommage à leur
président mohammed zia ul-haq et les
premières heures de la matinée ils ont
envahi la capitale pakistanaise pour
saluer cet homme qui sera resté onze ans
à la tête du pays depuis son coup d'état
en 1977 avec la population de nombreuses
délégations étrangères dont le
secrétaire d'état américain george
shultz mais aussi une trentaine de chefs
d'état comme celui de l'inde ou de
turquie
après une courte prière et une dernière
salve d'honneur 21 coups de canon tirés
par l'armée pakistanaise le président
dia il a été inhumé en début d'après
midi
enfin en ce qui concerne les causes de
l'accident d'avion qui a coûté la vie au
numéro un pakistanais la thèse du
sabotage semble de plus en plus probable
le fils de zia ul-haq a même directement
mis en cause
l'urss je reviens à l'instant à la
pologne je vous disais à l'instant donc
le la direction suprême des forces
armées polonaises étaient réunis à
varsovie première décision mise en état
d' alerte des forces de l'ordre dans la
région de haute silésie des patrouilles
armées ont fait leur apparition dans les
rues des localités minières qui sont
actuellement touchés par la grève des
ouvriers les soldats sont en tenue de
combat mitraillette en bandoulière ils
circulent en grand nombre dans les rues
de ces localités
ils ont établi des barrages et ils
contrôlent systématiquement les
véhicules qui passent en afrique du sud
les médecins qui soit une leader
nationaliste nelson mandela emprisonné
depuis 25 ans font un pronostic très
positif sur la guérison totale d'une
tuberculose dont il souffre
c'est d'ailleurs la première fois que
l'on apprend officiellement de quelle
maladie est atteint nelson mandel en
france après les accidents de chemin de
fer de l'été la démission du président
de la sncf monsieur rouvillois le
gouvernement va proposer pour le
remplacer monsieur jacques fournier qui
est l'actuel président du gaz de france
un heureux événement heureux événement
avec 5 aces 5 x est heureux et 1 5s à
événement pour une jeune femme de lyon
qui après neuf ans de stérilité et sept
tentatives de fécondation manqué vient
de mettre au monde
cinq petits bébés ce couple a bénéficié
d'une nouvelle technique qui se
rapproche le plus possible de la
fécondation naturelle naturelle pardon
son nom anglais c'est gift en français
ça veut dire qu'ado éric perrin
cinq bébés d'un seul coup margot sarah
clerc mathieu et manon ont lancé leur
premier cri mardi soir à lyon ce sont
des quintuplés leur mère françoise
périssent venait de subir un traitement
contre la stérilité
au cours des neuf dernières années elle
a par cette fois expérimenté la méthode
dite du lift qui consiste à placer
ovules et spermatozoïdes directement
dans les trompes
c'est là que se fait la fécondation
servant un espoir très important parce
qu'on en ait encore début mai c'est une
technique qui s'est démocratisée très
vite et qui est très facile qui
nécessitent pas que dans la fécondation
in vitro des procédés chimiques et
biologiques très important ces
techniques qu'elle soit naturelle
pourrait un plomb de choses qu'on a
prélevé sont les manipuler
pour augmenter les chances de réussite
on implante plusieurs ovocytes tous
susceptibles de donner à foetus ce qui
explique que c'est souvent dans le cas
de traitement contre la stérilité qui
lie à des naissances multiples il existe
certes une méthode dite de l'aspiration
pour les parents qui ne désirent pas
avoir plusieurs enfants d'un coup mais
elle comporte un risque certain il est
vrai par ailleurs que les femmes qui
pendant plusieurs années ont attendu un
bébé sont comblés comme cette future
maman qui après deux ans décès se
retrouve enceinte de triplés très bien
comité colbert c'est le nom d'un
organisme qui regroupe les grands
commerçants et industriels de luxe comme
les couturiers ou les bijoutiers pour ne
citer qu'eux récemment ce comité colbert
a commandé une enquête pour essayer de
mieux comprendre de mieux cerner ce que
les jeunes entendent par lux conclusion
un seul mot mais plusieurs définitions
valérie fournier france brice leur art
le cher le bo aucun préjugé aucun
complexe
les jeunes n'ont pas peur du luxe ils
ont même en majorité le style grand
bourgeois en rêve ou en réalité mais
pour moi le luxe et c'est ce qui est
cher mais c'est surtout ce qui est rare
le luxe est ce qu'on crève de posséder
c'est ce qu'on connaît je crois est ce
qu'on ce qu'on aimerait avoir
et le luxe a peut être aussi le silence
ça peut être laisse pas fait pour
certains vous ça peut être la liberté
tout simplement
du raisonnable sur les jeunes amateurs
du luxe grand bourgeois tiennent aux
signes extérieurs de richesse
traditionnelles valeurs du luxe chez les
jeunes moins utopique plus
individualiste leur passion la réussite
sociale leur luxe eux tout simplement
c'est ça du luxe
non ça c'est pas lui qui travaille à mon
avis le luxe et pour faire un petit peu
ce qu'on vaut pourtant
dec
c'est pouvoir effectivement bosser
l'ancien bâtiment c'est parce que ça
passe par un côté matériel
obligatoirement tout est un téléphone
qui fait une bonne voie
contact les beaux matériaux mais pas
forcément mon avis c'est avant tout la
réalisation d'une ambition une catégorie
qui n'entrent pas dans le schéma du
comité colbert à l'origine du sondage
un comité qui regroupe les 70 grandes
marques françaises et qui pèse 20
milliards de francs
reste le luxe des excentriques luxe et
la dérision dans l'argent lors de touche
et me jean droit à 300 dans une soirée
de gala se moque un petit peu du luxe el
fna
c'est un appel formidable renouveau au
renouvellement aux produits nouveaux est
ce que les membres du comité colbert
sont prêts le faire chez moi s'ils sont
prêts à faire lors des cas ils doivent
le faire
innovation créativité les fabricants du
luxe français doivent séduire les
acheteurs de demain héritiers ou futurs
leaders ont terminé je vais vous
demander de regarder attentivement ce
document à première vue vous allez
penser trucage cinéma et pourtant non
clos les mains regarde
bruno gouvy c'est un fou de seurre sur
l'eau et sur la neige c'était un
champion alors il a voulu surfer dans
l'air un hélicoptère un parachute une
planche
le rêve est devenu réalité
le seul risque c'est de partir sur le
dos puis tête en bas car le surf risque
de gêner l'ouverture du parachute
mais pour bruno pas de problème il
maîtrise parfaitement la technique
avant de vous donner des nouvelles du
tiercé je voudrais vous lire une dépêche
qui vient de tomber à propos du conflit
en irak vous dit tout à l'heure que la
paix était en place depuis ce matin 5
heures tout cas la trêve le cessez le
feu est bien il ya déjà eu une violation
du cessez-le-feu un soldat irakien a été
tué selon bagdad un observé observateurs
militaires de l'onu a constaté cette
violation l'iranienne pour l'instant les
forces irakiennes n'ont pas riposté je
vous disais tout à l'heure
paix fragile cela se confirme avec cette
dépêche
le tir s'est d'abord les résultats du
jour
voici les résultats de l'arrivée du
tiercé d'aujourd'hui 4 11 10 voyez
s'inscrire les rapports sur l'écran
rapport également pour le quarté 4 11 10
et 5
quant aux pronostics pour demain les
voici le 5 et le 9 le 8 le 6 le 3 le 13
sept
et de lui voilà ce journal est terminé
le dernier vous sera présentée tout à
l'heure en fin de programme par isabelle
des fleurs mais tout de suite après le
journal et avant votre soirée sur
antenne 2 les prévisions météo avec josé
blanc la fia a pu aussi des indications
pour ceux qui sont sur la route du
retour je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne à demain 13h au
soir